היי, שמי אוליביה ליינס וברוכים הבאים חזרה ל-Quantum Computing in Practice. זהו פרק שני - Quantum
circuits. אנחנו הולכים לכסות כמה נושאים בשיעור של היום, אבל מה שאני רוצה שתקחו איתכם הוא שלושה דברים: אחד, מה מחשבי IBM
quantum בעצם הם, כדי שלפחות תהיה לכם תמונה גסה בראש של מה אתם עושים כשאתם שולחים עבודה לאחד מהם דרך
הענן. שניים, מה זה Qiskit, מה זה Primitives ואיך אנחנו יכולים להשתמש בהם כדי ליצור ולהריץ quantum circuits.
אנחנו גם נדון ברמה גבוהה בסוגים השונים של מעבדי IBM Quantum שזמינים ומה מבדיל אחד מהשני. ושלוש,
לבסוף, תהליך העבודה הטיפוסי שאנחנו עוקבים אחריו כדי להריץ ניסויים בקנה מידה גדול. זה כולל בחירת ה-Primitives
הטובים ביותר למקרה השימוש שלכם, מיפוי בעיה ל-quantum circuit, והפעלת error suppression ו-mitigation שמאפשרים
לנו לסחוט כמה שיותר כוח מהמכונות האלה. עכשיו, יש כאן הרבה מידע אבל תישארו איתי,
כי בקרוב אנחנו הולכים לחבר את הכל יחד בהקשר של כמה דוגמאות אמיתיות. קודם כל, בואו נדבר בקצרה על qubits ועל ה-Quantum
Hardware בפועל. כמי שעובדת בניסויים, אני יכולה להבטיח לכם שזה מרתק וזה באמת עוזר לחבר את הנקודות
ולדמיין מה בעצם קורה כשעבודות נשלחות למחשב קוונטי דרך הענן. המעבדים שאנחנו
הולכים להשתמש בהם בנויים עם superconducting transmon qubits. ככה נראה מעבד IBM quantum קטן.
עכשיו, הריבועים הקטנים האלה כאן הם ה-qubits עצמם, אז יש סך הכל חמישה על השבב הזה. ה-transmon
עצמו הוא קבל והוא מורכב משני לוחות מתכת מחוברים במקביל עם משרן לא-ליניארי שנקרא
Josephson junction. אבל כדי לראות את ה-Josephson junction צריך להתקרב עוד יותר. הוא נוצר משתי
שכבות חופפות של מתכת על-מוליכה, והמקום בו שני החלקים חופפים ונוגעים הוא הצומת. Josephson
Junction הוא אלמנט שאפשר להשתמש בו כדי ליצור אטום מלאכותי עם רמות אנרגיה מרובות, ואנחנו מבודדים
את שתי רמות האנרגיה התחתונות בתור מצב ה-qubit שלנו. הקווים המתולתלים כאן מייצגים את ה-microwave resonators,
בעצם קווי שידור דו-ממדיים שמצומדים ל-qubit. עכשיו, כשאנחנו מתכנתים gate, זה בעצם שווה ערך לבחירת
פולס מיקרוגל מכויל ברמה גבוהה, והתדר, האמפליטודה, הצורה ומשך הזמן הספציפיים של הפולסים האלה גורמים
ל-qubit לעשות דברים ספציפיים. ההוראות לפולס המיקרוגל עוברות מהמחשב שלכם לענן
ואז נקראות ומפורשות על ידי אלקטרוניקת בקרה בטמפרטורת חדר, שלוקחת את ההוראות האלה ופיזית
מייצרת את הפולסים. אנחנו קוראים להם פולסי מיקרוגל כי כולם נופלים בתוך רוחב הפס של תדר מיקרוגל,
שהוא בסביבות 1 GHz. אחרי שתיבות הבקרה בטמפרטורת חדר יוצרות את הפולסים, הם נוסעים דרך הכבלים
לתוך מקרר הדילול ובסופו של דבר לשבב הקוונטי שלנו. האות נכנס ל-resonators דרך
חיבור wire bond על הפדים האלה, ואז הוא זורם לאורך קו השידור לתוך ה-qubits שלנו. עכשיו, אני יודעת שכל זה אולי
היה קצת טכני והפרטים האלה לא חיוניים להבנה להמשך, אבל אני מקווה שעכשיו אתם
יכולים לפחות לדמיין את המערכת הפיזית שאתם עומדים לעבוד איתה. אז איפה המחשבים הקוונטיים האלה
בעצם נמצאים? ובכן, ל-IBM יש עשרות מחשבים קוונטיים בכל רחבי העולם ולאחרונה שדרגנו את הצי שלנו
כך שיכלול רק מעבדים של 100+ qubits. כפי שהזכרתי בשיעור הקודם, חלקם ממוקמים במרכז נתונים של IBM
Quantum בצפון מדינת ניו יורק. המערכות האלה פרוסות בכל רחבי הענן לשימוש של כולם, וחלק
מהם הם מערכות ייעודיות מותקנות במקום, כולל כל האלקטרוניקה שגורמת להם לעבוד, שתומכות בשותפים שלנו
ברשת IBM Quantum. עכשיו בואו נדבר על Qiskit, שזה ערכת פיתוח התוכנה בקוד פתוח של IBM
שמיועדת לעבודה על מחשבים קוונטיים. מעכשיו אני אתייחס לזה בתור ה-Qiskit SDK. יש גם את
אקוסיסטם Qiskit, שהוא אוסף של תוכנה, מדריכים ופונקציות שבונים על או מרחיבים את הפונקציונליות הליבתית של Qiskit, וגם Qiskit
Runtime, שהוא שירות מחשוב קוונטי ומודל תכנות שמאפשר למשתמשים לתכנן ולהריץ ביעילות
את עומסי העבודה הקוונטיים שלהם באמצעות Qiskit Primitives. ו-Primitive הוא בעצם אבן בניין קטנה
שאפשר להשתמש בה כדי לתכנן circuits גדולים יותר או עבודה. שני ה-Primitives שהכי חשובים לנו הם
ה-sampler וה-estimator, שנדון בהם יותר לעומק בקרוב. אם עדיין לא הורדתם והתקנתם את
ה-Qiskit SDK, אין זמן טוב יותר מעכשיו. Qiskit 1.0 שוחרר לאחרונה והוא יותר ביצועי ו
יציב מאי פעם. אז למי מכם שרק מתחילים, הגעתם בזמן המושלם. למי מכם
שכבר מכירים את Qiskit, תצטרכו להוריד ולהתקין מחדש את הגרסה החדשה ביותר. אנחנו ממליצים להשתמש
ב-pip כדי להתקין Qiskit ו-Qiskit Runtime ולהריץ אותם דרך Jupyter notebook בדפדפן אינטרנט לבחירתכם. אז אתם גם תצטרכו
להתקין Jupyter Notebook או Jupyter Lab למקרה שעדיין לא עשיתם את זה. הכלים האלה כולם חינמיים ואתם
יכולים להפעיל אותם על המכונה המקומית שלכם בלי שום עלות. הקפידו להוסיף את Qiskit עם אפשרות
ה-visualization כדי שזה יעבוד עם Jupyter ויאפשר לכם לצייר גרפים. תצטרכו גם להגדיר סביבת Python וירטואלית ויש
הוראות איך לעשות את זה בדף ההתקנה של Qiskit שמקושר כאן. ברגע שהכרתם את Qiskit ואתם
מוכנים להריץ עבודות על מחשבים קוונטיים אמיתיים, תצטרכו להירשם ב-quantum.com וליצור IBM Quantum
API token, ויש גם קישור לזה כאן. הדרכה מפורטת איך לעשות את זה, עקבו אחרי כל
ההוראות בדף התיעוד שלנו כמו שהזכרתי, או שאתם יכולים לצפות בסרטון ההתקנה של Coding with Qiskit כאן.
שניהם מקושרים ובתיאור. עכשיו אנחנו כמעט מוכנים להתחיל לדבר על quantum
circuits. מכיוון שהמטרה של הקורס הזה היא ללמד אתכם, הקהל, איך להגדיל את העבודות שלכם לקנה מידה של 100+
qubits, אני מאמינה שהדרך הכי בונה קדימה היא קודם כל לשקול את תהליך העבודה הכולל שאנחנו הולכים לעקוב אחריו, והדרך הכי קלה
להבין תהליך עבודה טיפוסי של מחשוב קוונטי היא דרך Qiskit patterns. Qiskit patterns הם מסגרת מושגית שמאפשרת למשתמשים להריץ
עומסי עבודה קוונטיים על ידי יישום שלבים מסוימים עם כלים מודולריים. זה מאפשר למשימות מחשוב קוונטי להתבצע על ידי
תשתית מחשוב הטרוגנית חזקה. השלבים האלה יכולים להתבצע כשירות ויכולים
לכלול ניהול משאבים, שמאפשר הרכבה חלקה של יכולות חדשות ככל שהן מפותחות. הנה
השלבים העיקריים, שמשתמשי Qiskit מנוסים כנראה כבר מכירים. השלב הראשון הוא מיפוי. שלב זה
מפרמל איך אנחנו לוקחים בעיה כללית שמעניינת אותנו ומבינים איך למפות אותה למחשב קוונטי
בצורת circuit. הבא הוא אופטימיזציה. בשלב זה אנחנו משתמשים ב-Qiskit transpiler כדי לנתב ולפרוס את
ה-circuit על חומרה קוונטית פיזית ממש. זה כולל תרגום ה-quantum gates הבודדים לרצפים
של פעולות שמבוצעות על החומרה, וכן אופטימיזציה בפריסה של אותם gates. הבא, אנחנו
מריצים. Qiskit Runtime Primitives מספקים את הממשק לחומרת IBM Quantum שמאפשר ל-circuits מתורגמים לרוץ.
שלב זה כולל גם שימוש בטכניקות error suppression ו-mitigation, שברובן יכולות להיות מופשטות מהמשתמש. לבסוף, אנחנו מעבדים.
בשלב זה, הנתונים מהמעבד הקוונטי עצמו מעובדים ומספקים למשתמש תוצאות שימושיות על הבעיה המקורית. בעצם, שלב זה
כולל כל ניתוח נוסף של הנתונים שנאספו. עכשיו אנחנו מוכנים לדון בבסיס של תוכניות קוונטיות,
שהם quantum circuits. בתקווה אתם כבר מכירים quantum circuits, אבל למקרה שלא, אולי תרצו קודם לבדוק את שיעור
שלוש, Quantum Circuits, שהוא חלק מ-Understanding Quantum Information and Computation, מקושר למטה. אנחנו רק
הולכים לתת כאן רענון קצר. quantum circuit הוא רשת של quantum gates ומדידות מחוברים
על ידי חוטים שמייצגים את ה-qubits. אפשר לקרוא quantum circuits כמו תווים מוזיקליים, משמאל לימין, מתחילים בזמן
אפס שנמצא בצד השמאלי לגמרי. qubits וירטואליים, כלומר qubits שעדיין לא הוקצו ל-qubit
פיזי ממש על מעבד, רשומים בסדר עולה מלמעלה למטה. ברגע שהגדרנו את ה-circuit שלנו, אנחנו יכולים להוסיף
gates אליו. gates של qubit בודד, כמו ה-Hadamard gate כאן, משפיעים רק על ה-qubit שעל החוט שלו הם ממוקמים. gates
מרובי qubits, כמו ה-CNOT הזה, משפיעים על שניים או יותר qubits שמחוברים על ידי ה-gate. כאן בדוגמה הזו, המצב של qubit אחד משתנה
בהתאם למצב של qubit אפס. אחרי שכל ה-gates הופעלו, אנחנו יכולים לבצע מדידות,
שגורמות לתוצאות להיכתב על רגיסטרים קלאסיים. מאפיין אחד חשוב במיוחד של
circuit הוא העומק שלו. העומק של quantum circuit הוא המספר המינימלי של שכבות quantum gates שמבוצעות
במקביל שנדרש להשלים את החישוב שמוגדר על ידי ה-circuit. להבהיר, quantum gates יכולים להתבצע
במקביל, או במילים אחרות בדיוק באותו זמן, בכל פעם שאין להם qubits משותפים. אבל אם שניים או יותר
gates פועלים על אותם qubits, אז אנחנו לא יכולים לבצע אותם במקביל. אנחנו חייבים לבצע אותם אחד אחרי השני. כי quantum gates לוקחים זמן
ליישום, עומק ה-circuit מתאים בערך לכמות הזמן שנדרשת למחשב קוונטי להריץ את
ה-circuit. אז לדעת את עומק ה-circuit חשוב כדי לדעת אם אפשר להשתמש בו על מכשיר מסוים או לא. זה גם יגיד לנו אם יש
סיכוי טוב שיצא תוצאה מדויקת. הבא, בואו נעבור לבחירת מעבד קוונטי. IBM
שחררה לאחרונה צי חדש לגמרי של מעבדים, כולם עם יותר מ-100 qubits, ואתם יכולים להתחבר ל-quantum.com כדי לראות
לאילו מעבדים יש לכם גישה. המעבדים כולם קרויים על שם ציפורים, מסיבות, והלוגואים השונים
מייצגים סוגים שונים של מעבדים. אז למשל, אלה מייצגים מעבדי Eagle, והאייקון הזה הוא
Heron. השם של המעבדים הספציפיים נמצא גם למעלה. כולם קרויים על שם ערים, אבל זה
לא בהכרח אומר שהמעבד ממוקם פיזית בעיר הזו. אלה פשוט שמות. מספר qubits,
EPLG ו-CLOPS הם גם גורמים שמופיעים ברשימה. בואו נעבור על כל אחד מהם.
qubits, זה די מובן מאליו. qubits זה פשוט המספר הכולל של qubits שזמינים לשימוש על אותו מעבד קוונטי או
QPU. EPLG מייצג errors per layered gate, שמודד את שגיאת תהליך ה-gate הממוצעת בשרשרת שכבתית של
100 qubits. בעצם אתם רוצים שזה יהיה כמה שיותר קטן. CLOPS מייצג circuit layer operations per second, וזה
מודד כמה שכבות של quantum volume circuit, שהוא circuit וירטואלי, QPU יכול להריץ ליחידת זמן.
ככל שהמספר גבוה יותר, כך אנחנו יכולים לחשב מהר יותר. זה שווה ערך למה ש-FLOPS אומר במחשוב קלאסי. עכשיו,
המדדים השונים האלה עשויים להיות יותר או פחות חשובים בהתאם לתחום היישום הספציפי שמעניין אתכם. הבא, בואו נדון ברמה גבוהה
על מיפוי ל-quantum circuits. השלב הראשון הוא שלב המיפוי, שבעצם עונה על השאלה: איך
אני מתרגם את הבעיה שלי ל-quantum circuit שאפשר להריץ על חומרה קוונטית? אין ספק בזה,
מיפוי זו בעיה קשה וזה תחום מחקר פעיל. לפעמים רק היכולת לקחת בעיה חישובית
ולהמציא רצף של quantum gates שעוזר לפתור אותה זה החלק הכי קשה. אין שיטה חסינת-תקלות
שמבטיחה הצלחה, אבל יש הנחיות מומלצות ודוגמאות של בעיות שאנחנו כבר יודעים איך
למפות. ההנחיה הראשונה היא לתת למחשבים קלאסיים לעשות כל עבודה שהם יותר טובים בה בעצמם. משימות
שקלות למחשבים קלאסיים כנראה לא ירוויחו ממחשב קוונטי. מחשבים קוונטיים הם לבעיות שקשות קלאסית. כמובן,
אם זו הפעם הראשונה שלכם עם Qiskit או מחשב קוונטי, אל תדאגו למצוא בעיה שמורכבת חישובית. תפרקו את זה
לבעיות קטנות יותר שאתם יכולים ללמוד לטפל בהן לפני שאתם קופצים ישר לפרויקט בקנה מידה utility. הבא, תרגמו את
התוצאות של הבעיה שאתם רוצים למדוד או להבין לבעיית ערך ציפייה או בעיית
דגימה. לרוב סוגי הבעיות זה בעצם מתאים לחישוב פונקציית עלות. פונקציית עלות היא
פונקציה ספציפית לבעיה שמגדירה את המטרה של הבעיה כמשהו שצריך למזער או למקסם, והן יכולות
לשמש כדי לראות כמה טוב מצב ניסיון או פתרון מתפקדים ביחס למטרה הזו.
אפשר ליישם את המושג הזה על יישומים שונים בכימיה, למידת מכונה, פיננסים, אופטימיזציה ועוד.
זכרו גם שלחומרה שאתם הולכים להשתמש בה יש טופולוגיה ספציפית. חלק מה-qubits לא מחוברים
וחלק כן, ובסופו של דבר תצטרכו למפות את הבעיה שלכם ל-circuit שמייצג את זה. מעבדי IBM Quantum
משתמשים במה שנקרא טופולוגיית heavy hex, שבעצם שווה ערך לחיבורי qubits בסריג משושה,
שנכנס לזה יותר מאוחר בקורס. לעת עתה, הדבר הכי חשוב לזכור הוא שהשלב הזה דורש
תרגול. אתם צריכים הבנה טובה לא רק של הבעיה שלכם אלא גם של יכולות החומרה
הקוונטית, ואנחנו נעבור על דוגמה ומקרה שימוש ספציפיים מאוחר יותר כדי לראות איך אפשר לאזן את אלה בצורה
הטובה ביותר. עכשיו בואו נדון איך לבצע אופטימיזציה ל-circuit לחומרה שבחרנו. המטרה הכללית של שלב
האופטימיזציה היא למפות את כל ה-qubits הוירטואליים מה-circuit שלנו ל-qubits אמיתיים ממש איפשהו על
הטופולוגיה של המעבד. שם המשחק הוא לצמצם שגיאות כמה שאפשר. כדי לעשות את זה, קודם צריך
לנתב ולפרוס את ה-circuit שלנו ביעילות. דבר ראשון לזכור הוא שלא כל ה-qubits מחוברים, כמו
שכבר אמרתי. חלקם בעצם רחוקים אחד מהשני על השבב, אז אנחנו צריכים לצמצם או לבטל אינטראקציות למרחק
ארוך בכל הזדמנות אפשרית. אתם יכולים להפעיל רצף של swap gates בין qubits שכנים כדי להזיז מידע
של qubits, אבל swap gates יקרים ונוטים לשגיאות, אז יכולים להיות דרכים טובות יותר לעשות את זה. הבא, פריסה
וניתוב הם תהליכים איטרטיביים שמקצים qubit וירטואלי מה-circuit שלכם ל-qubit פיזי על
החומרה. אתם יכולים לעשות את זה ידנית, אבל יש גם כלים ב-Qiskit שיכולים לתת המלצות לפריסת
ה-qubit הפיזית בהתבסס על שיעורי שגיאה משוערים. הבא, אנחנו יכולים להרכיב רצפים של gates של qubit בודד שפועלים על אותו qubit
ל-gates בודדים, ואנחנו גם יכולים לפעמים להיפטר מ-gates מיותרים או שילובים של gates. למשל,
חלק משילובי gates אפשר לצמצם לשילובים פשוטים יותר, ולפעמים שילובי gates אפילו
שווים לאופרטור זהות פשוט, אז אנחנו יכולים פשוט לבטל אותם. אתם יכולים לעשות את זה אוטומטית באמצעות
ה-Qiskit transpiler, או שאתם יכולים לעשות את זה ידנית gate אחרי gate אם יש לכם סיבה טובה לעשות זאת ואתם רוצים
יותר שליטה. ברגע ששיפרנו את פריסת ה-circuit, הניתוב וספירת ה-gates, בין אם ידנית או באמצעות ה-Qiskit transpiler, אנחנו
בדרך כלל רוצים להמחיש את ה-circuit שלנו כדי לוודא שהתזמון של כל ה-gates הגיוני. יש ארגומנט שאפשר לסמן ב-transpiler כדי
להמחיש את ציר הזמן של ה-circuit שלכם ולוודא שהכל מסודר כמו שציפיתם. עכשיו בואו נדבר על error
suppression. error suppression מתייחס לטכניקות שונות שמשנות circuit בזמן קומפילציה כדי למזער שגיאות.
זה שונה מ-error mitigation, שמתרחש אחרי שה-circuit כבר רץ, ונגיע לזה בקרוב. שתי הצורות הנפוצות ביותר של
error suppression שאנחנו מנצלים הן dynamical decoupling ו-Pauli twirling. יהיו כאן כמה
פרטים טכניים, אבל אתם תמיד יכולים לחזור לזה מאוחר יותר. אז הראשון, dynamical decoupling, משמש
כדי לבטל ביעילות חלק מהרעש שמשפיע על ה-qubit על ידי הפעלת סדרה של gates שביחד שווים
לפעולת זהות, כמו רצפי XX, שהאפקט הנטו שלהם הוא לבטל בקירוב את ערוצי הרעש שמשפיעים
על ה-qubit. Pauli twirling היא דרך להכניס gates אקראיים כדי לפשט את הרעש הממוצע. האקראיות עוזרת
למנוע מהאפקטים של שגיאות שונות להצטבר מהר מדי, וגם הופכת את הרעש לקל יותר לאפיון.
עכשיו, השיטה הזו גם מהווה את הבסיס לטכניקת error mitigation, ואנחנו הולכים לדון בזה מאוחר יותר.
שוב, יש כאן הרבה מידע ואל תדאגו אם זה לא נכנס מיד. למזלנו, הרבה מזה אפשר לעשות אוטומטית באמצעות ה-Qiskit
transpiler. transpilation יכול להיות מסובך, אבל ה-transpilation הוא שלב כל כך קריטי להשגת utility בקנה מידה
גדול, שזה דורש הרבה ניסוי וטעייה כדי לשלוט בו ולהשיג את התוצאות הטובות ביותר. עכשיו אני רוצה לעשות
הפסקה קצרה כדי לדון ב-Qiskit transpiler וביכולות שלו קצת יותר. אעשה את זה ברמה מאוד גבוהה ונכנס לפרטים ונראה
כמה דוגמאות מאוחר יותר. באופן כללי, transpilation הוא התהליך של כתיבה מחדש של circuit קלט נתון כדי להתאים
לטופולוגיה ולמכשיר קוונטי ספציפי, ולבצע אופטימיזציה של ה-circuit להרצה ולעמידות מפני רעש. זה גם
כותב מחדש circuit נתון ל-basis gates של אותו מעבד קוונטי ספציפי שבחרתם להשתמש בו. ל-Qiskit יש ארבע
צינורות transpilation מובנים, ואלא אם אתם כבר מכירים אופטימיזציה של quantum circuits, אני בהחלט ממליצה להשתמש באחד מהצינורות
המובנים. כברירת מחדל, ה-transpiler כולל שישה שלבים אלה: initialization,
layout, routing, translation, optimization ו-scheduling. עכשיו, initialization מתייחס
לכל מעבר ראשוני שנדרש לפני שמתחילים להטמיע את ה-circuit על ה-backend. בדרך כלל זה כולל
פתיחת הוראות מותאמות אישית והמרת ה-circuit ל-gates של qubit בודד ושני qubits בלבד. שלב ה-layout מחיל
מיפוי layout שממפה את ה-qubits הוירטואליים ב-circuit ל-qubits פיזיים על backend. routing רץ אחרי שהוחל layout
ומזריק gates כמו swap gates לתוך ה-circuit המקורי כדי להפוך אותו לתואם לקישוריות
של ה-backend. השלב הרביעי הוא translation. בשלב זה ה-gates ב-circuit מתורגמים לסט ה-basis
של ה-backend היעד. הבא הוא optimization. שלב זה מריץ את לולאת האופטימיזציה הראשית
שוב ושוב עד שמתקיים תנאי, כמו הגעה לעומק יעד מסוים. יש לנו ארבע רמות אופטימיזציה
שונות שאנחנו יכולים לבחור מהן. האחרון הוא scheduling. שלב זה הוא למעברי scheduling מותאמי חומרה. ברמה
גבוהה, אפשר לחשוב על scheduling כהכנסת עיכובים ל-circuit כדי להתחשב בזמן סרק על ה-qubits
בין הרצת הוראות. אז כמו שאמרתי, יש ארבע רמות אופטימיזציה, מ-0 עד 3, כאשר
רמות אופטימיזציה גבוהות יותר לוקחות יותר זמן ומאמץ חישובי, אבל אתם עשויים לקבל circuit טוב יותר.
רמת אופטימיזציה אפס מיועדת לניסויי אפיון מכשיר ולכן רק ממפה את ה-circuit הקלט
לאילוצי ה-backend היעד. היא לא מבצעת שום אופטימיזציה. רמת אופטימיזציה שלוש
משקיעה את המאמץ הכי רב באופטימיזציה של ה-circuit. עם זאת, מכיוון שרבות מטכניקות האופטימיזציה
ב-transpiler מבוססות על היוריסטיקות, השקעת מאמץ חישובי נוסף לא תמיד מביאה לשיפור
באיכות ה-circuit הפלט. אם זה מעניין אתכם, בדקו את דפי ה-transpiler בתיעוד
Qiskit שמקושרים למטה. עכשיו אנחנו מוכנים לדון בהרצה בפועל של quantum circuit.
Qiskit Runtime Primitives מספקים ממשק לחומרת IBM Quantum והם גם מפשיטים error
suppression ו-mitigation מהמשתמש. ה-sampler primitive מחזיר את התפלגות ה-quasi-probability או counts,
שמייצגים את הסבירות למדוד מחרוזות ביט מסוימות, אפסים ואחדות. ה-estimator primitive מחזיר ערכי
ציפייה של observables שמתאימים לגדלים פיזיים. אז ביותר פירוט, ה-sampler מריץ את ה-circuit
מספר פעמים על מכשיר קוונטי, מבצע מדידות בכל ריצה, ובונה את התפלגות
ההסתברות מאיסוף אותם מחרוזות ביט. ככל שמריצים יותר ריצות או shots, התוצאות
יהיו מדויקות יותר, אבל זה דורש יותר זמן ומשאבים קוונטיים. ספציפית, הוא מחשב את
ההסתברות לקבל כל מצב basis סטנדרטי אפשרי על ידי מדידת המצב שהוכן על ידי ה-circuit. ה-
estimator של Qiskit משתמש בתהליך אלגברי מורכב כדי לאמוד את ערך הציפייה על מכשיר קוונטי אמיתי, על ידי
פירוק ה-observable לשילוב של observables אחרים שיש להם בסיסי eigen ידועים, והרצה מתחת
למכסה של ה-Primitives הן הטכניקות שנקראות error mitigation. error mitigation הוא מונח גג לכל זה, והוא
בעצם מתייחס לטכניקות שמאפשרות לנו לצמצם שגיאות circuit על ידי מידול רעש המכשיר בזמן
ההרצה. בדרך כלל זה מביא לתקורת עיבוד קדם קוונטי שקשורה לאימון המודל, ותקורת
עיבוד שלאחר קלאסי כדי למתן שגיאות בתוצאות הגולמיות באמצעות מודל שנוצר. אבל בתמורה לתקורה
הזו, אנחנו מסוגלים לקבל תוצאות הרבה יותר מדויקות. יש מספר טכניקות שאנחנו יכולים ליישם עבור
error mitigation, ואנחנו הולכים לעבור על שלוש מהן ביותר פירוט. שימו לב עם זאת שזה תחום של
מחקר פעיל, אז טכניקות חדשות כנראה יומצאו וישנות ימשיכו להשתפר. רמת
ה-resilience מגדילה את העלות, או במילים אחרות את הזמן שלוקח להריץ את העבודה. כבר אמרנו שב-
resilience level אפס ה-transpiler לא באמת עושה משהו ל-circuit שלכם, אבל החל מ-resilience level אחד הוא מציג שיטה שנקראת twirled
readout error extinction, או T-Rex בקיצור. twirled readout error extinction משתמש ב-Pauli twirling כדי
למתן רעש, שזה משהו שכבר נגענו בו. זו טכניקה מאוד כללית ויעילה
שבאופן אינטואיטיבי הופכת את הרעש לפחות לא-סדיר וקל יותר להתמודדות. החל מ-resilience level שתיים אנחנו
מציגים zero noise extrapolation, או ZNE בקיצור. זו טכניקה פופולרית שלאחרונה הייתה לנו הרבה
הצלחה איתה. הרעיון מאחורי ZNE אולי קצת מפתיע. אנחנו בעצם מוסיפים
רעש נוסף מעל מה שכבר קיים, אבל מה שזה עושה הוא מאפשר לנו לבצע אקסטרפולציה בכיוון ההפוך כדי
לחזות איך התוצאות היו נראות אם היה פחות רעש. אפשר לעשות את זה בכמה דרכים ספציפיות, למשל אנחנו
יכולים למתוח את ה-gates כדי להפוך אותם לארוכים יותר ולכן יותר נוטים לשגיאה, או שאנחנו יכולים להריץ יותר gates שבסופו של דבר
מביאים לפעולת זהות, אז ה-circuit לא באמת משתנה פונקציונלית אבל אנחנו בכוונה דוגמים יותר
רעש. אתם חייבים לעשות את זה לכל circuit וכל ערך ציפייה שאתם רוצים לעקוב אחריו, אז אתם
יכולים לראות איך זה יכול להיות מאוד יקר מבחינת הזמן הנדרש. סוג אחד ספציפי של ZNE נקרא
probabilistic error amplification, PEA בקיצור. ברגע שלמדנו מודל רעש עבור gate, PEA עובד על ידי דגימת
שגיאות מאותו מודל רעש והזרקתן בכוונה ל-circuit. כמו שהזכרתי, הרבה
טכניקות חדשות ממשיכות להתפתח ובתקווה יישמו ככל שנראה יותר ויותר נכנסות למשחק. יש רק עוד צורה אחת של
error mitigation שאני רוצה לדון בה, שנקראת probabilistic error cancellation. במקום להיות ברמת resilience
שלישית, PEC היא יכולת מיוחדת שצריך להפעיל ידנית ב-Qiskit, כי המשאבים החישוביים
שנדרשים לה לא מסתדרים טוב בהשוואה לטכניקות error mitigation אחרות שדיברנו עליהן.
מתחילים בלמידה על הרעש שמשפיע על ה-circuit שלכם על ידי הרצת circuits של noise learning או noise characterization
לכל שכבה ייחודית של gates של שני qubits שנמצאת ב-circuit שלכם. התוצאות האלה מאפשרות לכם לתאר את הרעש
במונחים של Pauli operators. ברגע שאתם יודעים את מונחי הרעש האלה, אתם יכולים לשנות את ה-circuits שלכם כך
שבעצם יהיו להם ה-PECs ההפוכים מובנים כדי לבטל את ערוצי הרעש האלה. במובנים מסוימים התהליך הזה
דומה לאוזניות מבטלות רעש. אולם, הדרך הזו לבטל את הרעש מאוד יקרה, עם זמן ריצה
שגדל באופן אקספוננציאלי במספר ה-gates, אז היא אולי לא הבחירה הטובה ביותר ל-circuit מאוד גדול. אנחנו
הגענו עכשיו לשלב האחרון, עיבוד שלאחר. בסוף, אם עשיתם עבודה טובה והפעלתם טכניקות error
mitigation נכונות, אולי תראו את התשובה הסופית שלכם זזה, כמו באיור הזה. התפלגות לא ממותנת,
שמוצגת בסגול, רחוקה למדי מערך הציפייה האמיתי, שמוצג כאן על ידי הקו הזה. אולם, ברגע שאנחנו מפעילים error
mitigation, אנחנו מקבלים התפלגות ממותנת, שמוצגת כאן בכחול, שהשיא שלה הרבה יותר קרוב לערך האמיתי. עכשיו,
כל זה בא במחיר, וכאן אנחנו יכולים לראות שהשונות, או רוחב ההתפלגות, גדל, שזה
לא מה שבדרך כלל רוצים. אבל הכל בא במחיר. למזלנו, אנחנו יכולים לפצות על זה על ידי הרצת יותר
shots, שגורמים להתפלגות להתכווץ חזרה לרמת אי-ודאות מקובלת. אז זהו בערך לשיעור הזה.
בפעם הבאה אנחנו הולכים לקחת את כל השלבים האלה ולחבר אותם ולעבוד דרך תחום ודוגמה
של עניין יישומי אמיתי. יש כמה דברים שאני יכולה להמליץ לעשות עד אז. אם עדיין לא עשיתם,
הקפידו להוריד ולהגדיר Qiskit 1.0. אתם יכולים גם לבדוק את השיעור המשויך לפרק הזה
ואת הפרק הקודם בפלטפורמת IBM Quantum Learning, ולבסוף, אם יש לכם עניין לחפור עוד ו
ללמוד עוד על טכניקות error mitigation, בדקו את אחד מהמקורות הרבים שקישרתי למטה. עד אז, נתראה בפעם הבאה.
[מוזיקה]